in principle problems with conceiving of
the universe well in principle problems
with science apply to the universe as a
whole because in science we're
constantly looking at interacting parts
within
and so then firstly how are you supposed
to perform an experiment twice on the
universe as a whole
because the universe is the entirety
okay you might expand it exactly on that
so what are the problems of theory what
else are the problems the in principle
problems not just pragmatically we can't
interact with all of the universe the in
principle problems with conducting
science or even thought experiments
about the universe as a whole
um
yes uh i can't but
before doing that let me reiterate uh
the distinction between the two
different meanings of of universe i mean
when the cosmologists
talk about the universe that's solid
science that's observable the universe
is what is
uh
the the universe was a cosmologist
it's uh
what is it
it's the the large-scale properties of
what we see around us
so uh
we look at that universe from the
outside right we have a telescope with
the telescope we count galaxies
so the telescope and us is the observer
the the galaxy is counted it's the
system we're observing
so it's fine it's it's perfectly fine we
can see this galaxy we see how much
they're moving apart from us we can
trace back
how compressed they were in the before
we have a system we can model it
um
and we're observing these degrees of
freedom uh
from from the outside in the sense that
we are not part of those degrees of
freedom we
we are
spatially inside but we're observing it
from not being one of them it's like if
you were i'm in this room and i study
the air of this room i can be inside the
room but i'm not the air
okay
so so that's fine on the other hand
uh the idea of describing the totality
of thing of ascribing a wave function
for instance through the totality of
things
which is common uh
i i don't think it's a good idea
because uh
uh let's be real specific the wave
function of an object the wave function
of this pen
uh it's a way of computing
where this pen is gonna
show up with respect to me next
right right
so
when when i'm in a laboratory and and
and and and do some quantum measurement
uh and and i use the wave function the
quantum state for uh predicting what i'm
gonna see
uh i i'm deducing this wave function
from what i saw
okay i've seen this pen the spin of this
particle in one way goes to some
apparatus and i have the
probability of the
spin being this way or that way after
the pentagon supply that's a typical
super simplified calculation and to do
this calculation i use the quantum wave
function of this
of this uh of this pen but what is this
quantum wave function is what i
know about the pen
and it's a a a description
of of what should i expect of the pet so
it's something that regards the pain and
me
it's a it's a relative state and the
person who
first has
understood that
when used quantum states in quantum
mechanics we always talk about relative
space is evident
uh
in uh
several decades ago
everett has understood that states are
relative state so the quantum state of
an object is always relative to another
object okay this is a state is a
relational thing
and once you understand that
clearly
the totality of thing does not does not
have a quantum state
because unless you believe there is god
then god thinks do quantum experiments
on on the but then god is not part of
the universe you you have a
then you lose and god together don't
have a quantum state right so um the
the
the wave function of everything
of the universe in the sense of
everything um i think is not something
that should uh enter in is not a useful
notion in physics the
wave functions are relational notions
that connect a system with another
system
considered observer